the recent indictment of Alec Baldwin
has brought to light numerous other
incidents in which movie people were
taken into custody these are just a few
of the most notorious and unusual cases
of onset arrests to date
in 2021 cinematographer Helena Hutchins
was killed when a prop gun held by actor
Alec Baldwin discharged during the
making of the western movie rust the
accident Drew intense scrutiny by both
legal and media professionals who opined
furiously over issues of set safety and
debated who Bear's responsibility for
the accident Baldwin was handed what he
believed to be a cold gun or one without
live ammunition he claims no
responsibility for the shooting sought
to avoid financial responsibility for
Hutchins death and even sued crew
members over claims of negligence I
think with rust it was a perfect storm
of you know the armor the assistant
director the culture that was on set the
rushing the times quoted investigators
interviews with the film's armorer
Hannah Gutierrez Reid who claims she
loaded and checked the gun but added I
wish I would have checked in more in
January 2023 prosecutors in New Mexico
where the accident occurred announced
they sought to charge Baldwin and
Gutierrez read with involuntary
manslaughter officials revealed that the
prop gun involved in the shooting could
not have discharged ammunition without
its trigger being pulled well the
trigger wasn't pulled I didn't pull the
trigger Baldwin has vehemently denied
doing so but Santa Fe County District
Attorney Mary Carmack altwese has
claimed that Baldwin should have
properly checked the gun however
Baldwin's assertion that actors have
never been responsible for gun safety on
sets is backed by the actors Union
sagaftra the union issued a statement
that noted an actor's job is not to be a
Firearms or weapons expert the rust case
remains ongoing while filming a segment
for the 1983 Anthology film Twilight
Zone the movie actor Vic Morrow and two
child performers were killed during a
sequence in which maro's character and
the children run to a waiting helicopter
the chopper was incapacitated by special
effects explosions and plummeted to the
ground killing Morrow 60 year old Renee
Shin Yi Chen and seven-year-old Mika
dinlay the tragedy led to indictments
for involuntary manslaughter for
director John Landis the helicopters
pilot Dorsey Wingo and three others
involved with the film The 10-month
Trial was closely followed by the media
and members of the film industry and in
the end all five defendants were
acquitted Landis went on to direct
Coming to America and other projects
though for some defendants the case
spelled the end of their careers I'm
sorry I think it's inappropriate for me
at this time to say anything the deadly
Twilight Zone accident inspired change
in the industry John Silva a vice
president at Warner Brothers which
released Twilight Zone created a
committee to establish onset safety
standards with the help of the unions
Silva and the committee laid the
groundwork for the injury and illness
prevention program iippp a set of
guidelines issued to Studios and
regularly updated to reflect developing
standards though injuries and even
fatalities have continued to occur on
movie sets the iippp has led to Greater
attention to Safety in the film and
television workplace
although he's known today as an
oscar-winning actor and filmmaker as
well as an outspoken social and
political activist Sean Penn's early
career was marked by altercations with
the media and the public the mid-1980s
in particular saw pen charged with
misdemeanor assault and battery on
several occasions including a fight with
an extra on the set of the Dennis Hopper
directed film colors in 1987. an extra
on the film photographed pen and co-star
Robert Duvall during a break in filming
but Penn reportedly objected and spat at
him before striking him several times
the assault charge violated Penn's
probation on a previous battery charge
which he had already broken due to
misdemeanor charges of reckless driving
and driving under the influence of
alcohol in May 1987. I did some
Municipal Court commissioner Julian
Cathey sentenced the actor to 60 days in
jail for the assault and reckless
driving charges and imposed an
additional two years probation the
incident would be Penn's Last Visit to
court until 2009 when he was given 36
months probation and 300 hours of
community service for assaulting a
photographer A Chorus of mixed and
dismissive reviews wasn't the only
indignity Ryan Gosling experienced as a
result of his 2014 directorial debut
with the experimental feature Lost River
Gosling was arrested while scouting
locations for the project in Detroit
Michigan where he had recently filmed
George Clooney's 2011 feature The Ides
of March Gosling remained in Detroit
after that film wrapped to shoot footage
of empty buildings throughout the city
that appears in the opening of Lost
River we're gonna be fine we have to do
it it's the right thing to do and
nothing bad happens when you're doing
the right thing unfortunately Gosling
ran afoul of Detroit police according to
the actor he was arrested for allegedly
trying to steal copper wire from an
abandoned location Gosling told the Los
Angeles Times I'm not proud that I was
arrested but it did give me one of the
central pieces for the main character in
Lost River in the film Ian decastiker
plays a teenager who scrounges burnt out
buildings for wire in order to help his
mother make ends meet the 2014 death of
camera assistant Sarah Jones on the set
of Midnight Rider made director Randall
Miller the only filmmaker in Motion
Picture history to receive a prison
sentence for an onset fatality Jones was
struck and killed by a train on the
first day of filming on writer a biopic
of rocker Greg Allman charges of
criminal trespassing and involuntary
manslaughter were filed against Miller
his wife producer Jody Savin and two
other members of the production team he
had been told don't go on those tracks
and he did anyway in exchange for
dropping the charges against seven
Miller agreed to a plea deal that
sentenced him to two years in jail and
eight years probation Miller spent a
year Behind Bars before his release in
2016 though he returned to court in 2021
for violating one of the terms of his
probation which was to refrain from
directing films until the completion of
his sentence Miller directed The 2019
feature Higher Grounds but avoided
returning to prison because he thought
he was only forbidden from overseeing
any safety precautions on the production
according to deadline more than 80
people have died due to Onset accidents
in the past hundred years but prior to
Miller's conviction only two people had
been prosecuted on such charges pathe
Film Studio Vice President John C Flynn
and production manager Harry Lally who
were indicted for second-degree
manslaughter in 1929 when a fire at the
Studio killed 10 people the charges were
later dismissed by the New York Court of
Appeals
before he helped to revolutionize the
modern horror movie with the zombie
films including Night of the Living Dead
and Dawn of the Dead Reddit director
George A Romero was a New York City boy
dreaming of a career in the movies he
was inspired in part by Michael Powell
and Emerick pressberger's vibrant
fantasy Tales of Hoffman of which he
later said that made me feel that gee
maybe I could figure this medium out
everyone says what
but that's my favorite film of all time
it's a fantasy film it's like countless
other would-be filmmakers Romero
borrowed a camera and began
experimenting one of his earliest
efforts an eight millimeter science
fiction film called The Man from the
meteor led to his first arrest he told
NPR the man from the meteor was
ultimately shot with his own ray gun and
fell flaming off the roof where I lived
to get the shot Romero lit a dummy on
fire and threw it off the top of a
building without obtaining permission
from the NYPD who quickly arrested the
14 year old as he recalled I was all the
way by the police and my parents were
called it was in a serious arrest I
didn't have to spend the night in jail
or anything director rajairo deodato's
1980 horror exploitation film Cannibal
Holocaust helped create the found
footage sub-genre it presented in
extremely convincing but entirely fake
documentary about a team of Rogue
filmmakers tormenting indigenous people
and animals in the Amazon jungle before
receiving a gruesome comeuppance at the
hands of a cannibalistic tribe it's
unbelievable it's
horrible the film's extreme violence
which unfortunately included some real
animal deaths looked so convincing to
authorities in deodata's Native Italy
that he was charged with murdering his
cast members and faced a 30-year
sentence charges were dropped after
deodato produced the actors who played
the force Lane filmmakers in Cannibal
Holocaust though he still received a
four-month suspended sentence on
obscenity charges and was fined for
animal cruelty Cannibal Holocaust was
banned in Italy until 1984 and remains
available only in edited form in many
countries including the United Kingdom
and New Zealand before filmmaker John
Waters inspired the Tony award-winning
Broadway musical Hairspray with his 1988
film of the same name he was known for a
string of transgressive underground
films like female trouble polyester and
pink flamingos give us some of your
political beliefs kill everyone now
condone first degree murder Waters early
film skewered Notions of gender class
and politics with gleeful mix of bad
taste and Anarchy humor which often ran
afoul of sensor boards his vision landed
him in hot water with the police in his
hometown of Baltimore during the making
of his 1969 film Mondo trash show I
thought what can we do that isn't
against the law yet
something that will really freak people
out it is hilarious 1981 Memoir shock
value Waters explained that trash show
his first feature-length film featured a
scene in which his frequent star the
formidable drag performer Divine ran
over a nude male hitchhiker Waters
decided to film the scene on the campus
of John Hopkins University which
resulted in his arrest for conspiracy to
commit indecent exposure and accusations
that he and his friends were making
pornography the ever shrewd Waters
contacted the American civil liberties
Union for his defense and the resulting
trial earned coverage in variety and
other major Publications Waters torched
the District Attorney's Case by
screening one of his early films hagging
a black leather jacket which proved
trashy and self-consciously already but
definitely not obscene Waters told the
John Hopkins Hub they were so
disappointed Indie filmmaker Timothy
Christian characterized his decision to
use a quiet neighborhood in Saint Paul
Minnesota as the setting for a major
action sequence in his 2013 action drama
the Minnesota delivery as spur of the
moment unfortunately Christian's bursts
of inspiration also caused him to forget
two important facts permits are required
to shoot a movie in a residential area
and homeowners tend to freak out at the
side of armed strangers running amok on
their lawns the Saint Paul police were
summoned to the North End Neighborhood
on September 27 2013 where according to
investigators reports they found four
individuals some armed with handguns
taking cover behind a vehicle while
pointing the weapon Christian and three
of his actors were held in jail for
about 48 hours but were never charged
they eventually recovered their
equipment including his digital camera
and footage of the action scene
Christian told the Twin Cities Pioneer
Press we ended up using the shot I think
it was worth it the footage wasn't the
only souvenir from his run-in with the
police Christian also used a quote from
a police officer on the film's
promotional material it read it did
create a lot of fear in the neighborhood
as co-founder and CEO of Death Row
Records Marion Suge Knight was a
Powerhouse in the 1990s gangster rap
scene overseeing chart-topping releases
by artists like Dr Dre Snoop Dogg and
Tupac Shakur Knight had a reputation for
ruthlessness and was reportedly linked
to the deaths of Shakur and the
Notorious B.I.G two groundbreaking
rappers whose burners remain unsolved to
this day not guilty not guilty not
guilty in 2015 Knight was charged with
murder attempted murder and a hit and
run after an altercation with two men
that began on the set of Straight Outta
Compton a feature about the influential
rap group NWA after feuding with record
label owner Terry Carter and clebone
Sloan a consultant on Compton Knight got
in his car and followed the men to a
restaurant near the set video taken at
the scene showed Knight's car running
over Sloan twice and then hitting Carter
who later died of his injuries Knight
was out on bail in a robbery case at the
time of the accident that in addition to
previous convictions subjected him to
California's notorious three strikes law
in 2015 facing the possibility of a life
sentence Knight pleaded no contest to
the manslaughter charge and agreed to
serve 28 years in prison according to
the California Department of Corrections
and Rehabilitation Knight will not be
eligible for parole until 2034.
[Music]